all right baby let's do this thing
coffee on a Tuesday and vlog 39 so I
know it's not good to talk about
politics or religion in polite
conversation but flamewars be damned I'm
doing it I had quite a wonderful time
last Thursday watching the vice
presidential debate it was a Hootin and
Hollerin stripped to the waist
bare-knuckle boxing match
Twix Joey Mac and the spelt Poindexter
the debate range from Libya to Iran to
Medicare to taxes to abortion and that
Martha Raddatz was wonderful indeed and
though she held the debate by the scruff
of its neck she was not opposed to
letting the opponent's slug it out when
it came to blows because that's what
they went there to do that's democracy
let's take a look at one exchange that
interested me I I'm not allowed to show
letters but go on our website he sent me
two letters saying by the way can you
send me some stimulus money for
companies here in the state of Wisconsin
we sent millions of dollars you know I
did ask for stimulus Sheree right by the
way two occasions we we advocated for
constituents who are applying for grants
now Ryan and the romney-ryan ticket and
the House Republican caucus and Senate
Republicans and Republicans generally
have spent a lot of time decrying the
efficacy of the Recovery Act called by
many the stimulus package they spend a
lot of time saying how this didn't work
how it failed and their repetitive
persistence in this matter has worked
out pretty well for them considering
that this huge some would say signature
piece of legislation from the Obama
administration is barely ever talked
about by the administration itself but
as the exchange showed spell
Poindexter's own request for stimulus
funds for his state seems to contradict
his party's assertion that the stimulus
did nothing for small businesses in fact
the stimulus achieved a whole host of
things including getting aid to drowning
states tax cuts for middle income
Americans grants for schools based on
performance it paved the way for a smart
grid it accelerated the process of
digitizing health records it spent money
on homelessness prevention on
infrastructure get upgraded 236 miles of
flood control levees 350 military bases
waste water systems and 400,000 public
housing apartments it helped bring
broadband internet too far out
communities and it invested in future
technologies and fledgling industries an
example of both is green energy now this
in particular has Paul Ryan in a tizzy
90 billion dollars in green pork to
campaign contributors and special
interest groups but he himself urged
Labor Secretary Hilda solace to fund a
green jobs training program in Wisconsin
green energy is a special favorite of
mine when it comes to the Recovery Act
because at the end of the Bush
administration that sector was on the
edge about to das solar companies wind
companies biofuel companies were ready
to move their businesses to other places
in the world because in America the
money just wasn't there in just the
decade before Obama took office our
share in global solar production and
deployment fell from 40 percent to 8
percent the recovery acts investment in
green tech is a great example of how a
government should seek to effect change
without the billions of dollars in
grants from the stimulus green energy
companies were dead in the water
compared to dirty energy companies whose
costs from huge scale allowed them to
produce at a much cheaper and more
competitive rate not to mention the
billions in subsidies dirty was and is
getting from the government already
Green Tech needed help to bridge what's
called the valley of death that period
of time for startups when they acquire
lots of debt building their product and
achieving the economies of scale
necessary to make that business
profitable green tech was dying because
each of its various technologies was too
young or too risky for private investors
who could make easier money on other
things some will tell you that
government investment like the 90
billion dollars that green tech got in
the stimulus package is bad because it
crowds out private investment in 2009 at
the height of the recession when capital
money was nowhere the crowding out
argument doesn't really hold water the
Recovery Act actually crowded in private
investment by helping new technologies
solar wind battery biofuel bridge the
valley of death making the opportunity
sexier solar was dying now
it's one of the fastest growing
industries in the country and if we just
take a look at Romney's old five-point
plan here we'll see oh yes
second we'll give our
fellow-citizens the skills they need for
the jobs of today and the careers of
tomorrow jobs of tomorrow check so if
you want to learn more about the
Recovery Act I highly highly highly
recommend you read Michael Grunwald
new book the new New Deal it should be
required reading for anyone who is gonna
vote next month it's got pictures in it
too
look look look it's Joe Biden and
President Obama but just hanging out
hanging out but